I always think about and not to put
words in your mouth I just think about
how annoyed I would be that people are
almost trying to make you and kawhai
like the face of load management as if
you all don't want to play or you
wouldn't play if you could exactly does
it does it feel annoying to you it's
annoying it's annoying cuz ultimately
like we love basketball you know we love
to play We love to compete like that's
just how we are we love to to hoop um
but for people to say that you know
they're they're not going to play
they're they're missing game like we
don't intentionally want to miss games
obviously there's something going on or
obviously we're it's something that
we're trying to uh you know be mindful
of and be ahead of um and you know it's
not just us that are that it's not just
players that's involved in on those
decision it's you know it's Med or not
media it's uh uh medical staff it's you
know higher ups that that have say so on
these situations as well um um you know
obviously I feel players can override it
but we're mindful of our bodies um and
so yeah it gets annoying hearing noise
of are they going to play are they not
going to play like you know if we
haven't played or if we're not suiting
up there's something that's going on
that's that's keeping us out of that
game yeah you're like if I'm not playing
I didn't have a choice exactly exactly
absolutely